I am an assembly of a
quorum so let's do that in
the status quo from from
around after Chen jail
Cunningham
Fong get sent here Gloria
Grayson Holden Irwin McCarty
Medina here Mullin Obernolte
good great thank you a
subsequent members there are
four bills here we would like
to establish and making the
I consent but -- we need to
actually hear these bills so
we'll begin then with -- file
item number one which is AB
five twenty eight -- cures and
controlled substances -- on
all four items here it is a
high recommendation from chair
inner Republican recognition
of concur so having said that
the first item the next item
number one -- with respect to
eighty five twenty eight here's
a bill fourth that technical
men's and we respectfully
ask for I felt because -- I
am presenting this bill then
-- relations and and second
and -- members of the public
wishing to testify in support
of please feel free then
just to speak for a where are
currently located at thank you
for the accommodations please
thank you very much
with his cases passes to
the federal government
medical association is
similar witnesses in
support what is opposition
questions from the committee
yeah the California
association also support
Cristina do carro
California veterinary
medical association is
right
any opposition
questions for committee
sure would like to close
I respectfully ask private
question call the roll AB five
twenty eight Senate amendments
concurred and low hi well I pro
bloom I thank Chen I've Chen
aye Chiu Cunningham Eggman
Fong hi Fong aye Gipson
all right Gipson aye Gloria
I Grayson reason I Holden
Holden aye Irwin McCarty
Medina five million I Mullin
Obernolte I tank right
twelve part the bill is
out Mister lawyer fifteen
of nineteen thank you very
much -- members this is AB
fifteen nineteen our dental
board -- sense at extension
-- and -- this will it says
with a convene operations
of that that support I
respectfully ask forever
his biggest support
yeah
with account California Dahle
situation here in strong
supporter of all the affect
but any other supporters
have also productive
dental also twenty
fifteen Ford support
alright from the medical
association start
the bill that as any opposition
questions from the committee
okay
is it because we don't have
a microphone to lock up to go
to thank you good afternoon
-- serve as chairman of the
committee some Scott calling on
and we're waiting fellow
dentistry company based out of
southern California so right
and others in our industry
provide safe affordable in the
end airliners to Californians
many of them who otherwise
couldn't afford it we simply
don't have the ability
AB fifty nineteen came
here under the guise
of patient safety
without any medical or
scientific support that
radiology is always required
in order to correct mild to
moderate a lot of issues it is
not you also told the patients
could buy these products
online without rocking with the
doctor that's simply not true
that's always the case that
we do our California patients
are lined up with a license
California's doctor reported
of patients come to us over the
internet and in various miles
up for some of our competitors
the bill of medical history
thank of histories photographs
taken questions and send those
filters there are probably a
life sentence reviews are file
and the term is first whether
they're a candidate or not
twenty percent or so of the
patients that are reviewed
are not exactly because
they simply require review
more of what the doctor
-- more aggressive someone
asked for more information
one scene in the file they
refuse five a clinician
but the majority of our
customers are eligible
fortunately and receive
treatment that they have been
wishing they'd gotten for
many times their entire life
Dennis orthodontist additional
model okay around fourteen
hundred dollars for his
members I have another
financing for you all we
have in the members remember
children's birthday wishes
so
having already had enough sugar
-- so so what I was saying
is in the tradition while
dentist what the line is around
fourteen hundred dollars or
so -- through it three design
are lined up now G.
the turn around and sell it to
their patients in their office
right you were from five to
ten thousand dollars depending
on where their -- practices
will calculation state
my industry so the exact same
product from mild to moderate
she could for under nineteen
hundred dollars across the
board three individuals and
roll areas specifically in
California and cannot get
access to the dentist usually
for at all number of people
who simply cannot afford five
thousand dollars or more we
can change lives we do change
lives this is a customer by
road us actually two causes of
like running last week that I
thought what's showing we're
sharing with you that about
thirty seconds left right
five thank you very much my
daughter's an actual patient
she gets polluted schools
and attempted suicide your to
these factors your help means
the world you're giving her
confidence with their lives
the bill supporting the city
eight because it comes you
based on potentially some other
motives and that are ready
to take way mazing service
California -- recalling the
mystery as an option probably
is now have opposite in
otherwise not worth noting
in two thousand twelve the
FDA for the record we do
the prescription radiology
clinicians never before as any
state mandated use radiology
specially not only a few
minutes now this bill would
require that -- regardless
of whether the medically
necessary -- or not this is
not about patient safety this
is about competition you know
that everything they do to
make the choice harder for
Californians to protect you
one step closer to keeping call
dentistry matching making them
quickly considering making up
compete for lowering prices
and we're doing the right thing
my suggestion is to push
this language for your heart
industries suggested that come
to the table and help create a
policy that protects consumers
will give them choices I
believe and the industry
believes the regulations
important that consumer
protection important patient
protections important and we
should get a table for that the
legislative computer wrapped
up with right -- without the
legislation we're here to study
its impact on public health
and safety job losses in the
practice of dentistry as a
whole in the interim I taking
this suggestion thank you for
your time and their work in
your service thank you for your
testimony any other members
the public opposition right
sure number for each and then
went back that respectfully
here in opposition today and
having good oral health and a
smile that you can be confident
with is no small thing and
college I three technologies
in California are growing part
of making that people call for
all for more people -- every
day -- when this bill was in
the Senate we did ask -- as
my colleague mentioned for a
one year delay in the policy
provisions that are included
in the sense that bill we
thought that that would have
given -- this legislature and
the stakeholders including our
industry and that is the proper
time to figure out if this
is an appropriate policy to
move forward from the Taliban
street -- in California we
did ask for that we continue
to believe that that would
be the appropriate approach
understanding that for your
Gen -- but we do want to
make sure that will be for
understand that this is an
industry manager because five
access lower -- and so we need
to make sure that are moving
policies like this -- forward
that we're doing in a way that
will continue allow consumers
to access this in California
Mr turn members asking
public affairs on the
house don't recognize
everyone else in opposition
I am actually here on
these are a little bit late
there are also support or
opposition Barbara Bettcher too
many questions because it's a
question for you the opponents
is I understand that I heard
size model moderate -- what
the Dante there never case
for this is used for severe
issues it's not that they the
clinician so because the state
certified licensed doctor --
this size and shape -- and in
our case about one out of five
or turned away because they're
fifties again within the
conditions one of you -- but
no these a workers to the shops
and for more severe things
are needed going to break
in order -- if they are not
accepted by that Dr -- there's
many examples of that and not
just based on the aggressive
nature of art also based on
their medical and dental --
five surveys and one official
so in summary we're not the
support we're not supporting
-- more than mild moderate
senator Lynch as usual at
the head start which again
health regions nation we
respectfully disagree with
that -- characterization like
many complacent detail wars
you see in the better business
bureau receive because in
fact not review or looking he
only imagine how was number of
cases where they were assigned
it is a line with a had
severe or don't your problems
they don't look this year
Sonora they refuse actually
so they can't come to the
conclusion that that which is
and for the online providers
are children ever applied
for customers no they're
not -- they the okay I think
it is as a ministry for
treating the patients all
third goal three -- to be in
consideration and then at that
point couple reviews which
happens at different ages
-- typically in the future
it is the product that I
thought we were no it's not
thanks Richard okay any other
questions assembly where motion
a second for the testimony
was that correct correct okay
-- Mister will draw closer
they just want to I think
-- colleagues fire at their
house minutes support on the
sunset of this board -- and
the test me that you're heard
is very specific to consumer
protections that we want we
will not remove -- the doctor
from the conversation when we
are moving bone and that is
the consumer protection that
we have in place and so you'll
see a number of different --
conversations with respect
this issue moving forward
and the coming years -- but I
appreciate your acknowledgement
in consideration yet again
so respect the abstract the
effort will call the roll AB
fifty nineteenth motion Senate
minutes we can carry on love
hi so I pro Arambula bloom I've
let my child five Chen aye Chiu
Cunningham Eggman I mean I Fong
Fong aye Gipson aye Gloria hi
for aye Grayson Grayson aye
Holden aye Irwin McCarty Medina
right the deny Mullin I bought
my Obernolte Obernolte I take
fourteen the bill was out
the store you have a three
fifteen to one thank you
very much -- this is the
sensible for court reporters
I respectfully ask private
bill there's a motion a second
-- any members public was
to testify in support gross
anatomy definition report
in California -- one of bank
-- share for the hard work
you did on this now can we
laughed about that next year
of the ones he appreciate --
the attention to something
that a lot of people don't
focus on that thanks very much
other testimony and support
anyone in opposition
a non will bring back committee
questions I missed a lot
actually the question about
this just briefly -- one even
knows the bill's prevents
the board from issuing a
certificate for the practice
of shorthand reporting by
means of voice reading of voice
recognition technology can you
tell us why that was put in the
bill -- to believe that there's
some of the stakeholders --
had -- spoken specific to this
is the issue at hand to hand
which some of the technologies
and the utilization of what's
currently in existence but as
you've heard -- we're continue
to working with many of the
stakeholders and figure out a
way to some the best practices
that work for them -- similarly
as well too so -- this was
in a specific responsible we
had heard from many of the
different stakeholders okay I
just wanna make sure that we're
not preventing the industry
from adopting practices that
make them more efficient --
so are is this a conversation
or to continue to have yes
most certainly and that is a
commitment that out you can
make as well that's one the
other questions the ocean
second restored like close
respect that type of card will
call the roll AB fifteen twenty
motion Senate amendments to be
can hurt and flow I fly from
Arambula bloom my channel I've
Chen aye Chiu Cunningham I am
I I meant when I Fong Fong aye
Gipson aye Gipson aye Gloria
aye aye Grayson prison aye
Holden aye Irwin McCarty Medina
-- thirteen aye Mullin aye
Obernolte I don't think I ting
fourteen forty zero that bill
is out and finally Mr lower
your baby fifteen twenty
two yes thank you very much
of this is the border of
professional engineers land
surveyors and geologist for
additional for years -- to
sunset in two thousand twenty
four and I respectfully ask
right the okay as motion
circuit and members the public
fortunate testified sport
same known as a in opposition
say not any questions from
committee similar hello George
Bush just last forever for
world Kalra TV fifteen twenty
two motions on it and I'm not
speaking part and flow hi so
I broke Arambula bloom five
that my Chen aye Chen aye Chiu
Cunningham Eggman Fong Fong
aye Gipson five Gipson aye
Gloria isn't reason I Holden
Holden aye Irwin McCarty Medina
alright but you know I Mullin
Obernolte one of the I Ching
fourteen forty zero that goes
out Mr sure you're very very
much we'll figure out members
that would only a four items
so -- we leave though will
open then for an additional
five minutes -- well we are
still here thank you very much
Mr Mullin
you like a month
I was actually written this
aye aye aye aye yeah yeah
I I I I I was pretty funny
we should have been
a non engineers
thank you Mister chairman
thank you yeah I think so
what was -- five twenty
eight who the author is from
out of town the chair vote
it's Republican and didn't
recognize words support
yeah in nineteen twenty
the dental fifteen twenty
is quirk still hanging out
engineers land surveyors
Angela just so maybe fifteen
twenty two one four hi
for him this fortnight yes
he just for three
we can't find
really
here's disappear he's
on the sex be today
I am in on reading about
the bond was because
of his apparently we're
all playing offer for
is there a
of
everything everything
is aye aye is aye aye
because your a because I
characters one I
want to stay off okay
what happened the one the
dental yeah number two
everything else but healing
you're the only one we'll see
what happens tonight while the
rest worse IPO company over
fifteen twenty zero that'll
out fifteen twenty two
nineteen is -- that'll
okay
okay okay thank you Richard